même le haut baffie
non mais sans dec
j'en reviens pas posé avec laurent
ruquier au calme
la dame de tpm peu incognito ce qu'il en
reste qui n'en resterait un truc
simplement le port du masque c'était
juste un an et demi que ça dure mais
même problème et avec les mêmes
personnes c'est-à-dire bien souvent les
hommes alors messieurs soyez rassuré le
fait de mettre votre nez dans le masque
ne retient strictement rien à votre
virilité merci alors attention là j'en
bois dix films ou qui prennent des
photos je vous préviens tout de suite le
droit à l'image ses 1500 euros d'amande
et j'attaque automatiquement donc à rien
sur le net merci et là je suis en vie
alors cette maman elle va vous montrer
que quelque chose que je n'ai jamais vu
c'est à dire un enfant qui est content
de se faire laver le nez au sérum
physiologique elle a dû lui promet de
grosses récompenses et pourtant c'est un
geste qui est indispensable chez les
petits qui ne savent pas se moucher donc
on envoie le sérum physiologique
autrement dit de l'eau salée dans une
narine et comme vous le voyez ça doit
ressortir de l'autre côté normalement le
fait chez un enfant couché un coût d'un
côté un coup de l'autre mais c'est très
bon le sérum physiologique sans forcer
trop bien sûr parce que ça permet de
nettoyer le nez des enfants est
d'empêcher les otites de se développer
quand il a un roulement
[Musique]
ça me ferait bizarre surtout si je suis
bourré aussi moi je suis et c'est vrai
supplice de la chambre asma al anbaa
pour moi tu seras toujours mon père mais
chut on perd il doit y avoir un truc
sympa accomplissent un peu bourg man
avec son enfant papa enfants enfants
quoi si l'art 11 ans et moins sympa quoi
la complicité